so how do Sony film simulations work
Sony colors might come a little bit off
and not as pleasing as would like to be
at least straight out of camera but I
have a little fix for you by applying a
custom picture profile and color
settings we can actually shift colors in
different directions correcting Sunny
colors and actually make them look quite
amazing here's a little secret sauce
lower the temperature by 2,000 Kelvin
then go into color filter and push it to
Ember 7 and to correct the camera tint
either go magenta 1 or green one
depending on your camera Color cast by
applying custom settings we can shift
and remap colors in different directions
from here you can use a picture profile
options to further refine your color if
we check the before and after we can
definitely notice the color shift
happening especially in the yellows
which is very important for the skin
tones further proving you can correct
Sony colors straight out of camera and
get amazing J bags without any color
grading